we have a major story from the daily
wire this is crazy I my jaw hits the
floor uh hit the floor when I saw this
Matt Walsh uncover uh undercover
investigation catches trans Health Care
Providers rubber stamping sex change
surgeries basically they had a producer
call in and within 22 minutes in a
virtual appointment even after saying
they weren't dysphoric the person wrote
a letter saying they were and it's
simple there's a lot of money to be made
in rubber stamping these things and
sending them out and you are protected
politically when you make money this way
the daily wire reports some of the
nation's largest trans Healthcare
Providers are rubber stamping approvals
for life-altering sex change procedures
and even falsely representing health
diagnoses of patients so insurance
companies will cover the medical
expenses daily wire host Matt Walsh
revealed in a tweet thread Wednesday so
apparently these doctors will say
explicitly if we don't give you this
diagnosis the insurance will not cover
it so you need to be diagnosed this way
and then let me let me actually I think
I have the uh the thread here I think he
explicitly brings up that the his
undercover uh producer
says that uh he's not dysphoric let me
see
he says the letter keeps capitalizing or
key uh orchiectomy is that he pronounce
it without and before it as if it's just
been copy pasted into a template Greg
followed up to learn why he had been
diagnosed with gender dysphoria plume
admitted to this use letter templates
provided by wpath he says just checking
on this to make sure this will be okay
in the letter I'm not really considering
myself dysphoric so wanted to check on
that one thing otherwise letter looks
great the doctor says the care
coordinator Hi Chelsea look at this you
get iPhone says she her hers this is
redacted a care coordinator with plume I
will page your provider on this to see
what she says I know we rewrite we write
letters based on wpath templates but I
can ask your provider if it's necessary
to have it and if not perhaps it can be
removed later plumes nurse confirmed in
order for the surgery to be paid for the
dysphoria diagnosis would need to remain
at the same time the nurse appeared to
confuse it to why Chelsea Bussey had
requested testicle removal in the first
place
saying uh let's see he's uh so Chelsea
Bussey which is the undercover is a male
producer for Matt Walsh thanks for
getting back to me I was just saying I
don't feel this Fork right now but it's
okay to keep the letter right the nurse
says nurse practitioner oh okay well the
surgery is related to the gender
dysphoria which you which you diagnosed
with it is controlled with HRT but in
order to get the surgery to be paid for
a GCS it will need to be related to
genitis for you which you are diagnosed
with does that make sense or is the orki
not gender confirming
so it seems like
basically what they're uncovering
these these companies
they don't care they want the money they
want the money look I can't get my dog
on an airplane with a letter from a
doctor anymore but in 22 minutes you can
be castrated and it can be paid for by
insurance I mean this is sheer incentive
whole industry's Insanity right now it's
marketing they're marketing and look
it's the same as the vaxxas right and
they're marketing but they're protected
and this is the crazy thing they're
protected that's right Jimmy Dore had
such a great bit that I saw today he was
like when it came to Big Pharma people
would people say don't do your own
research the media comes out don't do
your own research it's like what that's
crazy we used to call doing your own
research reading yeah not to read and he
goes we would never that was an
excellent bit he said we would never
tell anyone to to to not do their own
research in any other area imagine if
you were like I think I'm gonna buy I'm
gonna go buy a new car don't look into
it
how am I supposed to know what car to
get ask the salesman he's the expert
yeah it was a great bit it's absolutely
fantastic salesman he's the experience
it's worth watching what we have with
big Pharma and these men medical
practices political protection far left
extremists saying do not look into it
and the media saying that's right if you
do something's wrong with you yep
remember when the New York Times wrote
not to think critically
I gotta tell you man if you I look if if
I don't know I don't know how to help
these people genuinely if they're like I
was told not to think critically so I
stopped so listen I mean since we were
like five years old right Nursery School
kindergarten you're told I mean it was
it was like the most ubiquitous
statement on the planet when he came to
doctors get a second opinion yeah until
we learned fauci's name then anyway if
you got a second opinion you were a
crazy conspiracy theorist you were
anti-science you didn't trust the
experts get me a break look at this is a
break this is crazy Matt Walsh post the
letter which says she reports ongoing
gender dysphoria despite the fact that
in texts the producer said I do not have
dysphoria right so this is also
something that we learned a number of
months ago when Jamie Reed who was
working at a clinic that was giving
treatment towards minors came out and
basically said that there's I'm sorry I
had a backup routine sorry sorry I had
to correct I have it backwards that was
the earlier tweet they then asked about
it and he then said he didn't have
dysphoria so my mistake sorry continue
no no I was just saying that uh
whistleblower named Jamie Reed who was
working at the St Louis transgender
Center was talking about the kind of
rubber stamp routine that happens here
and how there are these templates and
what they do is give people sort of tips
on what they can say to the therapist to
ensure that they're going to be given
the green light to go ahead with these
procedures I went to a doctor for a
checkup a little while ago like a month
ago and uh the doctor was like how have
you been feeling like mentally I was
like oh I'm existentially I got a lot of
stress you know the world economic order
the shifting and he's like you want
something for that yeah and I was like
do you want to like do a blood test on
me do you want a psychological like you
want to do an eval first or do you just
want to hand me some Prozac like the guy
just he was so ready to give me the the
medicine the the drugs yeah the medicine
the psychoactive whatever suppressants
or whatever the hell they are question
for you guys do we know which state uh
Greg was uh chatting with this company
do we know which state this company was
located in uh I think we we probably do
let me uh the reason I ask is is my next
question is going to be why isn't the
State Attorney General opening an
immediate insurance fraud investigation
on these providers oh I mean this is
insurance fraud this is true I want to
clarify what I I was saying with the
letter the so first the letters the the
letter is posted uh let me let me grab
it from uh this here we go so in tweet
number 13 it says three days later
problems in this letter to Chelsea busy
who does not exist saying he was
experiencing gender dysphoria the
producer then responded saying no I
don't the coordinator then responded
well it has to be in there
so keeping the letter as is saying this
person has dysphoria despite the person
texting saying no that's not true that's
insurance right that's blatant insurance
fraud I mean that there's your probable
cause also potentially medical malp
these are all over the country certain
apparently this is all over the country
but that but the intern for a criminal
that's a felony I mean the fact that the
other elements of it aren't criminal is
also that's a whole statement of our
laws yeah yeah and this is something I
mentioned Jamie Reed is a whistleblower
we also had a Helena kirschner on who
was describing her experience and the
fact that she went to Planned Parenthood
and was able to get the maximum dose she
could get after a relatively brief
conversation well I think she said she
didn't even talk to a doctor I mean
they're just playing this for a few
minutes and then she got the maximum
dose of testosterone and and initially
the the person she was speaking with
wasn't even going to give her that but
then she asked for it and they just gave
it to her I mean it's it's unbelievable
and so if you had any other field of
medicine where there were this many
scandals with this many different
whistleblowers coming for forward and
saying yeah there's actually this entire
complex set up around trying to give me
the proper answers to tell to other
Physicians to get certain treatments
that they're supposed to be vetting me
for objectively we'd be having a
national dialogue about it but we're not
when we're talking about literally
amputating body parts that cannot ever
be replaced or restored once they're
removed and
mutilating children
the medical marijuana rack was a racket
they were like that's you've got to tell
them that you have that's fair stress or
they won't give you the medical
marijuana card so you go and you're like
I have stress and then they give you the
card and then I think in some areas
right if if you said that you had that
kind of stress and they gave you a
medical card it actually precluded you
from being able to own a gun you'd for
12 months for 12 months but you'd have
to put that you're a current drug user
that stuff is amputating there's no
amputation it's it's a license to buy
marijuana which is ridiculous I don't
know much less serious than we're moving
about cutting an arm off or a body part
off or testicles or whatever yeah I'm
very libertarian on the weed issue I
think it's I couldn't care less couldn't
care less yeah it never never came
across any bad guys that were you know
trying to kill anybody but now I'm
starting to wonder completely honest are
you well I mean you've you've got all of
these uh detrimental things that they're
trying to pass on to people so I just
don't trust them oh that's a different
story but yeah if if Democrats came out
and they were like we actually think
Jello pudding's fantastic I'd be like
okay
I've said this before
I I'm totally against the federal War on
Drugs I think if a state wants to you
know ban marijuana I'm totally fine with
that but I remember when I was
graduating high school about 10 years
ago this was when the massive push was
happening for weed to be legalized and
when we actually started to see it
happen and all of the arguments being
made instead of making the libertarian
argument which I don't necessarily agree
with but which I think is a better
argument and that is this might be bad
for me but let me do it there was so
much mythologizing about how this is
gonna cure your cancer and it's a
miracle it's like okay you don't have to
do that either right you don't have to
push it all the way in that direction
but I hear you
that also made me more suspicious at the
time with just all of the master claims
about how great it was that's marketing
though yeah which look big Pharma is
just downright demonic in the way they
Market these oh yeah right I mean I mean
they're marketing you watch TV in the
middle of the day I have it on in the
background right when I'm working
every other commercial is a former
commercial for something the side
effects are it's a 45 second spot a 30
second spot the side effects and the
horrible disclaimers 29 seconds the side
effects often do what you're trying to
treat and then after that commercial
like two commercials later it's some Law
Firm it's like you could be entitled to
money right if you took this medicine
from that same company that's now been
recalled yes wait a minute there will be
one commercial that's like are you
suffering from Acid industry indigestion
see if acidoso is right is right for you
side effects may include explosive
diarrhea and headaches then the next
commercial is are you suffering from
headaches and explosive diarrhea see if
this drug is right for you because
Zantac is going to kill you you know no
it's it's nuts I mean it's just crazy
and I think we learned quite a bit about
big farm in the last few years but I
think I think what they've done you know
John Stossel did a good expose on it
years back where he he made a strong
argument for big form right I guess his
brother Works in that industry and he
was saying how on average they spend
about 800 this was then about 850
million dollars to up a drug and some
don't it work others do work but they're
just not prescribed and so he made a
good argument for why certain things
cost the way they do I don't think
anyone ever foresaw what we saw in the
last couple of years I mean you saw a
farmer commercial one every 10
commercials my friends and I are brought
to you by Pfizer yeah my buddies and I
are on a text chain one's a banker for
one of the large Banks but he's very
politically like-minded and we just run
jokes all day long like have you taken
your Sky Rizzy today do you have your
relaxation and your Prevagen like it's
just not every you know it's just crazy
every other commercial it was when they
told me not to question it I was like
what in this exactly yeah don't look
into it it yep yeah trust the experts
and also them saying that they weren't
looking into things right when fauci was
saying he wouldn't even entertain lab
leak he won't even entertain it you
won't even think about it really thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time